one of the ways you can beat AI fatigue is to walk in deep cold mode
this is very funny yes
I know we don't really write code as developer anymore
but again
there are instances where you need to dive into what you have
program things or write some instructions or refactor some things
it is very important that we read some of these things
because
those are the ways where things that you build can be meaningful
I'll give you one example
I had AI implement one future for me
but after the implementation
the UI was okay the back end was okay
the entire processes was okay
but again I haven't tested what the AI has done
I was still a bit not satisfied
because I didn't know how the AI implemented what I am seeing
and the fear for me is how am I gonna be sure
that what has been implemented is actually what I intended
and there are some reports out there that we have over 40%
of vulnerability in AI implementation
so if you're building for scale
if you're building for security
you have to be watchful that AI implements something and it's working
does not mean that's the end
and that doesn't necessarily mean that AI have done the wrong thing
so sometimes
you may really want to dive into the deep aspect of the code
to really know what is going on
and that's really what differentiates just vibe coders and actually
technology professional because at the end of the day
you wanna own the technology
you wanna own the logic
you wanna ensure that everything you're doing works as expected
so next time when AI does something
it is a time for you to really investigate
if what has been achieved is really what you intended
or you need to prompt it to do even more
or you even want to go into that and do it yourself
in a particular way that you want it to be done